good morning everyone
Hurricane durian has its sights set on
North Carolina we will be ready and we
will not underestimate the damage this
storm can cause North Carolina faces
deadly storm surge and inland flooding
the greatest threats are to our coastal
communities and their inland neighbors
Thursday is a day of high risk for flash
flooding in southeastern North Carolina
and we know all too well that
floodwaters can be deadly today is the
day to finish preparing and I urge
everyone to do so with safety in mind
unfortunately we are reporting our
state's first storm related death today
an 85 year old man in Columbus County
fell from a ladder while getting his
home ready for the storm and we're
keeping his family and our thoughts
residents of the Eastern Counties will
see weather conditions begin to
deteriorate late tonight and early
Thursday as the leading edge of Dorion
draws closer to our shores rainfall can
be as high as 15 inches in some areas
sea water surges will push high levels
of water to coastal communities
especially at high tide expect surges as
high as 4 to 7 feet above ground that is
normally dry along the southern coast
and the Outer Banks north that duck
could see a two to four foot surge we
expect high winds to arrive early
Thursday and increase through Friday
with some gusts up to 115 miles per hour
in some places last night I received
approval for a federal declaration of
emergency that I had requested on Monday
the federal declaration will speed up
federal aid
coming to the state including bringing
more help from FEMA and more military
personnel and resources for our
preparation there is a mandatory
evacuation order in effect for our
state's barrier islands and in total at
least 12 counties have issued partial or
full evacuations North Carolinians are
used to facing storms but please don't
let familiarity get in the way of good
judgment if you're in an area where an
evacuation has been ordered leave now
follow the directions of your local
officials don't try to ride it out it's
not worth putting your life at risk or
endangering first responders who might
have to save you local shelters are
openings to accommodate evacuees who
need a safe place to go as the storm
draws closer additional local
governments may order evacuations as
needed so more shelters are preparing to
open if and when they're needed we have
many school districts in Eastern North
Carolina that are closed today with at
least five others on an early release
scheduled with so much happening it's
important for people to have a trusted
storm related information source I want
to thank the media for providing much of
this information to people and North
Carolina has several resources to help
you both before and after the storm
passes
they include ready in Sea Org Drive in
Sea Org and we have a 2-1-1 hotline that
is open today for the hard-of-hearing
please dial eight eight eight eight nine
two one one six two and you can also get
help by texting NC dorian - eight nine
eight two one one to get information
this morning I spent time here at our
Emergency Operations Center and met with
almost every
who is here an incredible operation with
local state federal officials nonprofit
private companies all working together
to make sure we are ready for this storm
and I'm so grateful for the people who
work here and who are working all across
the state to make sure in North Carolina
is protected